PROFESSOR COPELAND: So,
the number 197.
And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to
add the three digits.
So 1 plus 9 plus 7 is 17.
Now what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to form a number out
of the last two digits
of the original
number and the new number.
9 plus 7 plus 17,
and that is 33.
And now I'm going to
do the same again.
So, it's 7 plus 17 plus 33,
and that gives me 57.
You're beginning to
get the idea.
17 plus 33 plus 57, and
that gives me 107.
And now--
ready, you've been
very patient--
the Keith number is
about to emerge.
33 plus 57 plus 107, and look
what I get when I do that.
I get 197.
BRADY HARAN: That's
quite interesting.
I can't decide if these would
be really, really rare or
really, really common.
Intuitively, it strikes me
that this would be rare.
PROFESSOR COPELAND:
They're very rare.
This is a number with
three digits.
There are only 80 of order 80
numbers, 80 Keith Numbers,
with less than--
BRADY HARAN: Of order 80.
Hang on.
I don't like this of order.
PROFESSOR COPELAND: There
are in fact 84.
84 Keith numbers with
less than 26 digits.
BRADY HARAN: Once you get more
than three digits, how do you
start this process?
PROFESSOR COPELAND: So you start
with 2785, for example.
Then you would begin your
process with 2 plus 7 plus 8
plus 5, which is equal to--
10, 17--
22.
And the next stage along the
line is you take the preceding
three digits and add the fourth
from the new number.
So it would be 7 plus
8 plus 5 plus 22.
There are, for example,
two-digit numbers.
OK, so if I take d equals 2,
and 14 is a Keith number,
you'd go 1 plus 4 is 5.
4 plus 5 is nine.
5 plus 9 is 14.
Mike Keith, who's a
mathematician and discovered
them in 1987--
for me, this is recreational
mathematics.
It's how I got into
My hero wasn't a physicist early
on, it was actually a
guy called Martin Gardner.
I'd never heard of [INAUDIBLE]
earlier on when I was
at school in Gauss.
But Martin Gardner was this guy,
brilliant mathematician,
that worked--
I knew him as the guy working
for "Scientific American." And
I subscribed to "Scientific
American," and I never
understood as a single
article I read.
I kept trying to, and so I'd
reread it, and it'd be a blur.
But you had these mathematics
puzzles at the back, and I
generally couldn't do them
either, but I was
fascinated by them.
They were little numerology
things.
And then I went and bought some
of his books and just got
into it, just playing around
with numbers, and you just get
to love them.
BRADY HARAN: So the people who
watch Numberphile and get a
bit sniffy about our
recreational maths videos,
what do you say to them?
PROFESSOR COPELAND:
Oh, you shouldn't.
You should just enjoy it.
Embrace it.
And just have fun.
Just have fun playing
around with them.
There's plenty of occasions when
you doodling thinking,
what shall I do.
And just play around with
numbers, and you'll be amazed
some of the coincidences
that can come up.
And out of some of these
things come major
breakthroughs.
We're not quite finished.
There's just a couple more
things which are around there.
There's one called the reverse
Keith, and this is where--
so again, it's best just to
show you an example of the
reverse Keith number.
It's where the reverse number
appears in the sequence.
So if I begin say with 12.
OK.
So we just follow the
prescription that we've had.
So we go 1 plus 2, 2 plus 3, 3
plus 5, 5 plus 8, 8 plus 13,
and that's equal to 21.
And that's your reverse
Keith number.
You've reversed the order of the
integers in the original.
There's even fewer of what you
could call Keith clusters.
Mike Keith has got a conjecture
about these Keith
numbers, his numbers.
He's allowed to have a
conjecture about his own
numbers, of course.
And they're to do with the
clustering of these numbers.
And what he's done is he's said,
how many ways can you
cluster the Keith numbers such
that in any cluster, which
could have--
of course, a cluster has to have
more than one number-- so
it could have two numbers, three
numbers, four numbers.
Each number in that cluster is
an integer multiple of the
lowest number.
His conjecture is
the following.
There are three that are known,
just three, and he says
he believes that's
all there are.
So I think it's quite an
interesting challenge for some
of the Numberphile people to go
and maybe find some more.
So--
BRADY HARAN: So what's
a Keith cluster?
PROFESSOR COPELAND: So
here's an example
of the Keith cluster.
So the number 14 and 28 are
both Keith numbers, and of
course, 28 is twice 14.
And another Keith cluster
is the number 1,004--
1,104 and then if I
double that 2,208.
You've also got to have
the same number of
digits in the sequence.
There is, remarkably, one
cluster of three Keith numbers
which is 31331, of course,
62662, 93993.
I think that's amazing.
Each of those are
Keith numbers.
They all satisfy the properties
that we've been
describing, and they
form this cluster.
So the conjecture
is that's it.
I used to do these puzzles on
the bus going to school.
I had to get two buses, and
I'd just try and do, well,
whatever I could.
Usually, I got stuck,
especially with the
geometrical ones.
He has geometrical puzzles
as well as sort of basic
algebraic ones.
And then he has his own
puzzles and paradoxes.
How can you get a infinite
number of people in a hotel
with an infinite number of
rooms and then double the
number of people and things?
It was great.